10 canel renovó como presidente en un
mal momento para el país la situación
actual de Cuba se debe entonces más a
los desaciertos de diez canel o son
fruto del contexto político y económico
que ha rodeado a la isla en estos años
gracias por la invitación no sería
simplista acusar azcanel desde ser
responsable por la profunda crisis
económica y política que sufre el
régimen cubano Este es el resultado de
60 años de políticas equivocadas tanto
económicas como
políticas y sociales que han llevado al
país a esta situación
a desafortunadamente para días canel le
tocó algo Bernal en estos últimos cinco
años
en cualquier otro lugar del mundo los
cinco años de presidencia de Díaz canel
le hubieran ocasionado por la renuncia o
la pérdida de esta elección solamente en
un régimen como el cubano un presidente
de una incompetencia tan Escandalosa
puede ser reelecto y reelecto de manera
tan digamos mayoritaria
bueno como decía antes en 2018 se
presentó Díaz canela como un presidente
continuista está este continuismo
tutelado aún por la figura de Raúl
Castro absolutamente en general Raúl
Castro estaba todavía activo estaba hoy
en la reunión
lo hemos visto en televisión saludando a
miembros de la asamblea nacional del
poder Popular en Cuba es todavía el
señor
Raúl Castro en general Raúl Castro sigue
siendo el líder más importante
fundacional de la revolución cubana
heredado de su hermano Fidel y mientras
Raúl Castro permanezca en condiciones de
gobernar desde detrás del telón en Cuba
nadie más gobernará Solamente
Raúl Castro y Díaz canel lo ha dicho muy
claro en sus cinco años de gobierno que
han pasado constantemente
haciendo referencia y diferencia al
General Castro como el verdadero poder
tras el poder Qué pasará entonces en
Cuba el día que ya no esté Raúl Castro
se podría haber una aperturismo o un
cambio de tendencia dentro del poder
eso habría que verlo es muy difícil de
predecir en un régimen tan opaco como es
el régimen cubano lo que es indiscutible
Es que la muerte de Raúl Castro va
a probablemente
conllevar un cambio bastante rápido en
la situación interna de Cuba sea en
dirección a un régimen
autoritario y aún en el control de una
oligarquía muy reducida al frente del
país tanto económica como políticamente
o preferiblemente en dirección a una
transición democrática que pueda
finalmente traer a Cuba de regreso a los
países libres de las Naciones libres
después de más de 70 años de dictaduras
quería preguntarle por la Nueva Ola
progresista en América Latina cree que
puede ayudar a salir a Cuba de este
bache De esta crisis o se necesitan
reformas más profundas para la nueva
legislatura que comienza
no ninguna solidaridad de izquierda
llega más allá de las declaraciones
públicas lo que Cuba necesita es y lo
que está buscando activamente es un
patrón como el que tuvo en el papel de
la unión soviética en su momento y
después en la Venezuela de Chávez hasta
digamos principios de los años 2000
cuando ya Venezuela se agotó Cuba es una
especie de parásito que termina chupando
la la generación de riqueza la
productividad de cualquier país al que
se asocia está intentando desde entonces
convertir a Estados Unidos en esa nación
digamos patrón que pueda mantener a este
régimen parásito pero no es posible
ningún otro país del mundo incluyendo
potencias como China o Rusia está en
condiciones o tiene la inclinación de
convertirse en el patrón de Cuba si Cuba
no hace reformas internas
rápidas y profundas este régimen va ante
escalabro